herzlich willkommen so wwm heute mit
niemand geringerem als das freut mich
ist da für den weiten weg nicht
gescheitert viele stationen habe ich
gehört mit der u bahn oder s bahn und du
weißt auf was du dich eingelassen hass
hinein wwf wer weiß mehr
und unser heutiges thema wichtig
supercool
ok dann hoffen wir mal das beste für
welche ersten suchergebnisse oder
welches erste suchergebnis erscheint
falls wurst lage wächst wenn man leute
einlädt hat eine zürich züricher web
agentur ist die lösung a ein
rasierwasser ist die lösung b c
studentisches fernsehen oder de eine
spinnenart ich bin ich bin also ich sag
jetzt mal die spinnen die spinnen aber
einloggen
also bei den anderen sachen fantasy
eigentlich wünsche ich mir vor dass es
eine spinne gibt die fristsetzung
spiderman tals okay okay dann will ich
nicht ich mag kein rasieren was dann
sage ich das kommt aber die will ich das
es gibt
wie willst du deswegen rief willst es
nicht einfach ich hoffe ich kann mein
wunsch dass universum schnell geht und
dass block b ein rasierer sagt ja und du
kannst das universum nicht verändern
verdammt ist die spinne richtig gewesen
ja ok
die fragen dann doch nicht sie klingen
leicht aber sind es dann doch nicht wie
lang ist die nächste frage
das erste video also wie lange ist das
erste video in deinem hauptkanal 77
minuten 19 sekunden b 3 55 c 5 09 oder
de 610 überlege gerade ich weiß welches
das video ist das ist schon mal dass
endlich auch erwartet die frage und ich
sag mal 6 10
ich glaube 7 noch was eventuell ein
bisschen zu lang fast 8 ich sag sechs
minuten ziehen
ok du lachst sechs minuten 10 1 d doch
das ist falsch war was ist es 509
verdammt erste videos 509 warum geht
sein anderes ich kann mich jetzt
natürlich auch total in die nesseln
gesetzt habe ich glaube dass das in den
kopf in den köpfen von berlin video
ich bilde mir ein dass es das ist was
die gegend laufe und leute belästigen
frage das risiko mich leute ja ok es
schließt wieder ins interview
ich setze mich wenn dann richtig aber
bisher ein bisschen okay ich nehme jetzt
vergleicht ist am mittwoch eine richtige
antwort geben zumindest eine kleine
chance die dritte frage die alles
entscheidende wird er jetzt den preis
bekommen oder würde ihn nicht bekommen
das entscheidet sich jetzt mit der frage
wie viele likes hat dellé floyd
facebook-seite 36.000 also heute relativ
kurz
das kann natürlich die parieren aber
heute an dem tag an dem wir das
interview führen also gestern war so
man dazu sagen gestern abend 36.000 b
32.000 41000 oder de 28.000 dann sind es
32 blocks b 2 jahre und heute ist nicht
ganz eine frage es gibt natürlich auch
einen preis haben wir okay okay okay ja
ich habe jetzt nicht ganz erkannt ist
nicht nur an mich glaube ich auch an die
jetzt schwer herford rang zwei ist schon
okay